[Musique]
moi déjouer mois du père noël
comme nous ils se préparent à la grande
nuit la nuit aisne qui nous fait déjà
lécher les vitrines éclatante de lumière
et le trésor vitrine où viennent
s'écraser leptine et de tous les enfants
du monde
tu connais le père noël tu l'as vu déjà
oui et tu sais qu'il va passer bientôt
chez toi dans ta cheminée qu'est ce que
tu lui as demandé et l'habitude euros
notre force ce magnifique que tu n'as
pas peur de la vitesse cet insecte a
demandé au père noël
non qu est ce que c est pas nous qui
gagnons et et le château fort à mon
camion
un camion même ça est un gars et toi
c'est toi
bonjour j'ai lu presse regarde-moi
qu'est ce que tu as demandé au père noël
pour lui le plus fort
il n'y a pas ou qu'est un pilote qui
fera monter la poupée sur le vélo à noah
on veut en aucun cas moi dix mots et
puis
cooper et comment tu la veux cette coupe
et qu'on la regarde
tu les paies un baiser et revoilà en
rangs serrés
toutes ces filles à chérir des filles
modèles paraît de toutes les séductions
mais il faut choisir avec soin ses ailes
akira notre affection
elles ont toutes les qualités il leur
manque même pas la parole
[Musique]